what's the pollination is evan packing
weekend i am testing a new series that i
want your feedback on and we'll see how
it goes this is the official launch soft
launch test of the series the idea is to
basically look at different categories
of books to try to filter down some of
the best books from different topics to
help you build and grow your business
and so to launch it I want to talk about
the top 5 marketing books I'm going to
list off the books and then we're going
to hear from the authors about what's
inside the book to give you a little bit
more context I hope you guys enjoy I'd
love to know your thoughts on this video
whether this series should continue or
not with other topics leave in the
comments below let me know alright so
coming in at number 5 is the power of
growth by Daymond John this book is
called the power of broken when you open
the book the first thing you read is the
power of broke is a mindset it exists in
all of us whether we have money
opportunities or advantages trouble is
most people don't recognize the power
for what it is they leave it alone or
maybe they don't even know it's there
what is the power abroad what do you
mean by the hash that hunger that's that
drive that's that instinct that nothing
is ever going to stop you and I'm
listening I'm not I'm not I'm not
sitting there saying that to to be broke
and not have those resources feed your
family and and and get great medical
attention is something we should
celebrate I'm not saying that by far but
I'm saying that if you're going to be in
a situation where you don't have the
things that you want in life and you
you're hungry then that's the situation
let's tap into it and the people that I
see utilize the power broke more than
anybody at all all the people that when
they reach a level of success they still
use and that's how they maintain this
success that hunger and drive and and
and we grew up at a time and age where
it was you need money to make money you
got to know somebody well I mean you
know look at me look at half this room
you know I grew up a you know
african-american short dyslexic got left
back one time almost got left back the
second time can can't dribble the
basketball can't sink and draw didn't
know anybody didn't go to college
I didn't stop me at all yeah right yeah
I had a I had a mother that really loved
me daily and I had some like-minded fool
partners and friends who would never let
me stop and I never let them stop and I
had a will and a drive and and and I
still have all those same things I still
rise & grind every single morning you
see me in a suit on TV handing out
millions of dollars looking like another
just buttoned up executive but it wasn't
always like that
you see I had a secret tool it was there
for me when I had absolutely nothing
when I thought I was loved until it led
me to everything you may think it's your
biggest weakness but if you wield it
properly
it will definitely be the key to your
success this is the power you're telling
me you couldn't be authentic or original
or come up with some concept no matter
what you'll have there's enough to do it
throat can break you or give you immense
energy if you're someone that refuses to
lose it's going to give you all the fuel
you need to continue to push through
the level of rejection and the heights
in which we're trying to aspire to it
times they're so insurmountable I mean
crazy the people who were in a position
to buy my book were not my target
audience so they didn't register for
them one of my favorite things is try
fail try again fail better beings
without capital is one of the greatest
gifts you can have if you're a nod to
the real capital isn't the most
important ingredient for business
anymore it's not for you to being
passionate and I want people to believe
that they can actually be whatever they
want to be do whatever they want to do
and believe the sky's the limit
you know people
[Music]
it will never be a perfect time he will
only you making time perfect coming in
at number four is hooked how to build
habit-forming products by NIR Eyal
[Music]
my name is near Al and I'm the author of
cook how to build habit-forming products
I wrote hooks for two reasons first I
wrote it for the product makers the
designers the innovators the
entrepreneurs people who are struggling
to build products help people live
better lives this book provides a
framework to help them build the right
things sooner to use the deeper
psychology of why users do the things
they do so that we can help them live
better fine
the second reason I wrote cloaked is
that I'm concerned the world is becoming
the potentially more addictive place
technology is not only becoming more
pervasive but also more persuasive and
so if we need to learn how to live with
these technologies how to put technology
in its place we have to understand the
deeper psychology driving why we use
these good services and so by
understanding how these products change
our behavior we can make sure that we
control our habits as opposed to our
habits controlling in command at number
three is GoPro seven steps to becoming a
network marketing professional by Eric
Warren GoPro seven steps to becoming a
network marketing professional we talk
about the skills that you need to
develop and a roadmap to start
developing those skills a lot of people
are surprised to learn that there's only
seven skills that you need to develop in
order to be a network marketing
profession seven skills not seven
hundred these skills are all learning oh
they're all doable and they're all
repeatable you can teach them to others
but you need to know what they are how
to develop them and how to practice and
get better I want to help the people
involved in the network marketing
profession I love the people the network
marketing profession
more than any other group of the world
because their courageous their
entrepreneurial - their cool
or they go against the grain this book
can help you to really kind of form a
lot the skill set that you need to
develop number one that you need to
teach number two and you need to
replicate number three you may have
heard some of these concepts here and
there but I haven't seen anywhere
anywhere in network marketing where we
put it all in one place the thing about
this building many read 160 page is
pretty logically laid out we're going to
be talking about the principles of
network marketing and also the skill set
involved in network marketing but when
people pick this up book up what I want
them to do is not just read it because
you can read it and logically kind of
understand it in one read but I wanted
to underline I wanted to highlight I
want to go back with a fresh mind on the
regular basis you say okay let me take a
look at how to find people to talk to
about my network marketing let me take a
look at I'm going to present or how I'm
going to promote for events so how I'm
going to get people started is different
skill set right I want you to learn it
so well that you could teach you okay
because when you can do that then your
organization is going to really take off
coming in at number two is the tipping
point how little things can make a big
difference
by Malcolm Gladwell couple years ago I
was covering the AIDS epidemic right so
I got very interested in the internal
dynamics of epidemics because they have
their own sort of weird logic and it
just began to occur to me that I didn't
understand why when we talk about
contagious things we confine our
conversation to viruses or to diseases
because cling-on of disease could be
attributed to other places
yeah well ideas but also it also yes
exactly that those same principles I
mean so many different things are other
things ideas trends song lyrics are
contagious in precisely the same way I
mean I talk in the book about the world
yawn if I say the word yarn long enough
you will start yawning and exactly
people watching a show will start
yawning that's an incredibly contagious
word and it's contagious in precisely
the same way as
I just mean everybody catches it or
every way to catching it it's a penis is
spreading from one source everywhere but
there's the same thing is true for I
think for particular for products or
ideas or behaviors especially I talk in
the book about all kinds of contagious
behaviors
well the tipping point is the word that
comes from from study of epidemics is to
describe that moment in the epidemic
when it explodes when the moment of
critical mass and if you look at every
epidemic there is always that moment
when the curve suddenly shoots up very
sharply and dramatically and so
understanding how you can get to the
tipping point is really this is the
critical question that would have mouths
epidemics are something that I spend a
lot of time on in the book people use
that phrase without ever saying what
they mean I get all the time someone
thought I was great what about and I had
never read an explanation an actual
attempt to pin down what that phenomenon
is if there is such a thing as word
about who starts it who sustains it who
creates it so I decided I might've
started yeah absolutely I think I
haven't mean the book the whole first
part of the book is an attempt to say
all right this personality is
responsible for starting word-of-mouth
this personality and I have profiles of
each of these kinds of people is
responsible for spreading it this is the
kind of person because it comes directly
from it's an idea borrowed directly from
disease from from diseases if you look
at disease epidemics they are started
and spread by a tiny tiny group of
exceptional people that same idea I
think is a really powerful way of
understanding this previously amorphous
concept of word about and taking a
number one spot is jab jab jab right
hook how to tell your story in a noisy
social world by Gary Vaynerchuk
[Music]
if you look at what's happening in the
current state of social there's too many
people trying to close on the first move
right every piece of content is by my
home by my wine by my agency just too
much selling and so to me what I'm
trying to transition organizations
people everybody really into is listen
you've got to become a media company and
a media company writes articles writes
articles and then has an ad writes
articles writes articles and then has an
ad and to me the thing that has
converted the best for me as a salesman
remember I'm not Mother Teresa I'm doing
this stuff under the context of business
sure it matters for education of world
peace and all that but any business for
me the best things work for me is give
give given and asked and to me I
translate that into genitive jab right
hook the book is about you know the
pieces of content and auditing a hundred
of them and showing people how to do it
but it ladders up to a thesis which is
what I'm going to talk about today more
than anything which is not theory but
being a practitioner there's way too
many of you watching this right now that
talk about being a social media expert
or knowing social media but aren't in
the depths in the deep sea of knowing
exactly what to do on Facebook Twitter
Tumblr Pinterest Instagram to convert
ROI I'm getting more on that kick
because I've come to realize people like
to do a lot of talking and not as much
executing bill asks what's the best way
for a right hook to seem like a jack
bill bill bill bill bill am I happy with
you because you've asked a question that
means so much to me and it's something
that so many of you are confused by Bill
I really appreciate you and I'm not
trying to sting it but it might feel a
little like that uh trying to make a
right hook feel like a jab is what 99%
of salespeople and businesses do that
end up failing it is in the clear
honesty and clear track of when I want
to do something nice for you I just do
it
this show I just want to take 15 or 20
minutes of my day to share the god-given
wisdom and the work experience and I
want all of you to watch it and I want
yes in return
now come 15 months from now 18 months
from now whether it's a book whether
it's a seminar whether it's an event
whether it's me selling rare toys who
knows what it might be
then I will clearly say buy this friggin
rare toy it's $9.99 buy it now but up
until that point I will have very clear
there will be no show when you're
watching the show and behind the scenes
right now there's subliminal music
pumping I the damn cat for $9.99
there is none of that and so there's a
massive confusion in the marketplace
bill that people want to disguise the
sale and there is no disguise
authentically all in all of it all in
give when it's time to get on the flip
side there's a crapload of Mother
Teresa's and think it's so nice and
awesome and if you're just good it's
good no you need to sell so when you
sell you say I'm selling I am selling
this and I feel comfortable when I put a
link out buy my book it's out buy it if
I've done anything for you buy it so the
answer to question is very simple there
is no version of that that is a losing
mentality and execution and I highly
recommend that you take it and you split
it very hard apart where the jabs are
clear and where the right hooks are
clear so those are the top 5 marketing
book suggestions for entrepreneurs
unless you know what do you guys think
this is a test of a new series did you
enjoy this too we continue it other the
categories we're going to cover your
views your engagement your loyalty to
this series will determine whether we
continue or not so let me know leave it
down the comments below thank you guys
want to your support I hope you enjoyed
this video if there's a 6 7 8 9 10 that
you want to add to this list that we
missed out also share that down in the
comments I believe in you hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where is much love
I'll see you soon